I actually am going to get to I'm gonna I'm gonna break to so
badly if I keep watching this. Holy [__] Slimy doesn't
get there. It is evil. It is actually evil. Ben Shapiro is actually
evil. They want the regime to crack down on those people, slaughter
those people, and then they could go, "Look, they're so evil,
guys. We need to keep bombing them."
There is a crazy amount happening today. Honestly, almost all
of it is around this Joe Kent resignation.
The National Counterterrorism Center director for Donald Trump.
Okay, he resigned today. And he resigned and he wrote a letter,
"After much reflection, I've decided to resign from my position
as director of National Counterterrorism Center effective today.
I cannot in good conscience support the ongoing war in Iran.
Iran posed no imminent threat to our nation, and it is clear
that we started this war due to pressure from Israel and its
powerful American lobby." Mark Levvin responds to this. I wonder
if this Joe Kent guy if this guy Joe Kent was about to get be
fired but quickly resigned first. That's how these things typically
work. He's part of the radical isolationist woke right cabal.
Dude,
these people just do like mad libs on all of their radical
isolationist
woke right cabal. Cool cool cool.
Watch how the left-wing media use him to attack the president
and the military campaign against Iran. in part that's why he
wrote that letter. I wonder if he was one of the leakers in the
administration just asking
The people who are very much anti-Israel first are not going
to like this at all.
Mark Levin is telling us that this is what a Nazi looks like.
For those who don't know, that's Joe Kent's deceased wife who
was killed in action in Syria. Those are Joe's motherless children.
You make your mind up on who if we should listen to Mark or Joe.
It's like Okay. Yeah. Like unfortunately this image of like the
two military veterans, one of which was killed in action. It's
like these are like American heroes by every every like Republican
measure. These are the American heroes. Okay. Benny Boy was very
upset. He was very mad.
>> Folks, don't fall for the propaganda. Iran is losing.
Not barely losing. They are getting scorched. Actually, one by
one, the leaders of the Islamic >> I'm going to I'm going
to hate everything about this. I'm gonna hate it all.
Oh boy.
Oh boy. Guys, we're destroying Iran. Okay.
And how's the economy doing again? What's the price of oil? Hold
on. Maybe. What's the price of oil right now? 93.99.
Okay. Multiple times ticking over $100 in the past couple days.
Not good. Not good at all. The Republic are being eliminated.
Generals, security chiefs, regime power brokers, all gone. The
Supreme Leader of Iran
is dead on day one. Okay, fine. No biggie, right? The regime
had a backup plan. They proclaimed his son Moabi,
an impotent, likely gay, half idiot Moa, as his successor. Even
daddy didn't want that to happen. Well, the problem is Moshtaba
has not been seen in weeks and he may be in a coma. Meanwhile,
Iran's >> Ben like trying to imitate all of Trump's mannerisms
is very embarrassing.
He went from like the primary never Trump guy to like literally
just imitating all of Trump's mannerisms.
That's very embarrassing. I don't know how you do that as a man.
Like I don't know how you try to maintain your masculinity
and after being just like brutally raped by Trump and his entire
movement this this badly. It's very it's very sad to watch. >> Structure
is shattered. Their missile capacity has been slashed by 90%.
Whatever is left of the regime is throwing a temper tantrum like
a toddler. So the real question isn't why Iran is losing. The
real question is why so many people in the west are pretending
they aren't. This is the Ben Shapiro show >> prediction.
Not a single person will say that Iran's doing well right now.
What they will say is Iran's making all of us hurt way more than
anyone can justify for the action. Like we are all worse for
this having happened, right? It doesn't matter how many schools
you blow up in Iran. It doesn't matter how many oil depots you
blow up. It doesn't matter if you devastate that ent entire country.
It wouldn't matter if you nuke that entire country. We're all
destroyed, okay? We're all the the the economy, the average person
is getting because of this. It's not about Iran winning, right?
About how much they're making us lose. But Ben, of course, he
doesn't give a about the average person, right? It's not, again,
it's not about Iran winning. They're making the rest of us lose.
They're making everybody else
That's what they're doing effectively. Ali Larijani, the secretary
of the Supreme National Security Council of Iran, will step in
as the leader. I mean, here he was walking around Tehran just
a couple of days ago. I mean, there he is, right? Everything's
fine. That was Alud's day or Jerusalem day. It was established
by the elder in 1979 to express support for the Palestinian mission
to destroy Israel. Well, he's competent and cruel, right? Well,
last night, Larjani, who you might remember from such banger
tweets as quote, "Our leaders have been and still are among the
people, but your leaders on Epstein's island, well, is no longer
among the people." >> Yeah, this is a banger tweet, though.
I'm sorry. Lani kind of won on that one, Ben. Okay. Your heroes,
his heroes died for their country. Okay. He kind of got you there.
He's kind of got you there, man. >> Like any people cuz
he's dead. He was killed last night in an Israeli air strike.
Okay, fine, I guess. I mean, at least Iran still has
Solmani, the head of the besiege. That's the who no American
has ever heard of. You're lucky if anybody knew Larajani, the
guy running the country. Nobody knows Solommani, the person running
the besiege after Mashaba was uh uplifted to Supreme Leader,
I'm sorry. >> The internal Iranian force dedicated to murdering
protesters and quashing descent. Well, sorry. Strike that. Last
night, Israel killed him also along with other top members of
the bases. And now, individual besiege checkpoints in Tyran are
being struck with Israeli drones.
In fact, according to the IDF intelligence head, a man named
Major General Schlommy Binder, quote, "Their command structure
is shattered. Their capabilities stripped down to the bone. What
you're seeing launched now is whatever scraps they can still
push out, that's their ceiling." The United States has so severely
degraded Iran's missile capabilities that the government has
been firing off in rather dulttery fashion individual missiles
like a kid whose tantrum is ending but is still kind of sporadically
kicking as he tires himself out and goes down for a nap. On day
one of this war, Iran launched 350 missiles. Today, they are
down to launching barely double digits. Their ballistic missile
capacity has been reduced by upward of 90%. How about drone launches?
Same story, 800.
Yeah, that's that's what I
I hope some American mother can quiet their child's sobs on next
Christmas Eve. Mom, why am I not getting any presents? Why don't
I get presents this Christmas Eve? Well, you see, sweetheart,
what we had to do was reduce Iran's capacity to to fire ballistic
missiles by 90%.
That's what we had to You don't get Christmas gifts because it
was really important to us that we reduced Iran's ability to
fire ballistic missiles by 90%. That's what That's what your
Christmas presents are gone for. Okay. We really hurt Iran.
Cool. Thanks, Ben. I'm I'm sure sure a bunch of Ben's kids, by
the way, get all the gifts. Ben's kids, they love Christmas.
Ben's kids doing fantastic.
Are is Ben struggling? Is Ben having trouble putting food on
the table for his family? No. Ben's totally fine. Ben's also
a piece of >> 100 drone launches day one down to 75 on
day 15 and even fewer yesterday. Their ballistic missile factories
have been destroyed. Their drone factories have been destroyed.
Their nuclear facilities have been destroyed or heavily damaged.
Don't believe me? Ask Muhammad Salum writing for, wait for it,
Al Jazer. Yep. There is a gigantic piece in Al Jazer, Qatar's
propaganda outlet, accurately explaining the toll this war has
now taken on Iran. Remember, Qatar is a half ally to Iran. Literally,
everybody knows Iran is bro. I we we all watch that. We all watch
Tyrron getting nuked every day. Figuratively,
everybody knows this.
>> I is he really going to sit here and be like, actually,
I just off thinking about how many Iranians have died. I think
I off thinking about all the infrastructure damage to Iran.
How is that in the American interest? Yeah, I'm not off to that.
I'm sorry. Even if it's an evil regime, I'm still not off to
that. I just don't love death and destruction that much. I don't
know what to tell you. That alone should tell you just where
things stand for the Iranians. The Qataris who play both sides
are now pretty clearly taking America's side. As Salom points
out in again all jazer, quote, the picture is not one of us failure.
It is one of systematic phased degradation of a threat. The previous
>> Oh, braid. Well, hold on. I think some people think
I don't Nobody thinks that Iran is like um doing well. I I don't
think even leftists think that. They think the wind condition
for Iran is making the rest of the world burn
and they're being effective in that goal, right? Making the rest
of the world like like just
I don't know, hurt.
But that doesn't mean that they're not getting destroyed themselves.
I you'd have to be blind not to see that >> administration's
allowed to grow for four decades.
The campaign has moved through two distinct phases. The first
suppressed Iran's air defenses, decapitated its command and control,
and degraded its missile and drone launch infrastructure. By
March 2nd, US Central Command announced local air superiority
over Western Iran and Tan achieved without the confirmed loss
of a single American or Israeli combat aircraft. The second phase
now underway targets Iran's defense industrial base, missile
production facilities, dual use research centers, and the underground
complexes where remaining stockpiles are stored. This is not
aimless bombing. It is a methodical campaign to ensure that what
has been destroyed cannot be rebuilt.
What about the straight of Hormuz? We keep hearing that, right?
Well, the chances of President Trump allowing the straight to
remain permanently closed are zero. That is not going to happen.
and leaving Iran in total control of the >> Nobody believes
that's going to happen. Dude, he just has to lie about
Nobody believes that Donald Trump was like, "Yeah, we're never
opening this trade again.
Nobody Nobody thinks this way, right? Just because Iran has a
few drones and the capacity to fire them from the shoreline."
Well, this is, shall we say, a shortterm problem.
Soon the Iranian government will have much larger problems because
it does feel as though all of this is a prelude to action by
the Iranian people themselves. President Trump noted that the
Iranians will head out into the streets soon when they feel more
secure. Here was the president yesterday. Guys,
Iran's taking action themselves.
We're totally not going to watch the Iranian people get slaughtered.
Uh Moody Morgan, they might try to help. They won't be able to
help enough. Okay. In fact, we just read an article at the beginning
of your stream. You should go back and and listen to it. Israel
basically thinks that anybody who rises up is just going to get
slaughtered. And they're basically hoping and encouraging another
mass slaughter to try to further manufacture consent for the
war. That's what it is. Nobody believes an uprising will be successful
in Iran.
Least of all the actual powers conducting the strikes,
okay? But they want it to happen because they want the regime
to crack down on those people, slaughter those people, and then
they could go, "Look, they're so evil, guys. We need to keep
bombing them. We need to keep going, guys. They're so evil.
>> So, the women had 250,000, even 500 people protesting
a year ago, and they shot women right through the middle of the
forehead with snipers.
And they didn't have to do many. About 10 went down bleeding
profusely
and
250 to 500,000
women went running in the other direction because
they can be brave, but they they're not stupid and they have
no gun. And you have snipers in buildings
specifically for this reason. It doesn't take long for that to
spread. And when that spreads, that crowd dispenses.
And nobody else has been able to do that. They killed a minimum
two weeks ago, 32,000 people. So, and they put out actually a
notice two days ago.
If you protest, if you protest, you will be shot and killed.
>> Well, something is going to change. The time is coming.
Chief rivals to the Iranian people are being individually eliminated.
Right now, the Iranian people have the Americans and the Israelis
actually flying air cover for them. Yes, of course. They're going
to have to brave death to take on the regime. And they did that.
>> Dude, it's actually so slimy. I actually am going to
get to I'm going to I'm going to break to so badly if I keep
watching this. Holy [__] dude. Ben has got to be
like honestly this is straight up like deplatforming level stuff.
Like he's People are doing this kind of propaganda and it's like
explicitly guys, you already got told on. You already got told
on. Everybody knows that those people are going to get slaughtered
if they try to rise up right now. Everybody knows it. So, everyone
doing this, I want you to watch Ben Shapiro and anybody else
who tries to say, "Oh, guys, rise up. Take back your country."
They all know Ben is a personal friend of Netanyahu. You think
he doesn't know that those people are going to get killed? You
think he doesn't know that for a fact when he goes and makes
this video? Every single day, my hatred for these people grows.
It's
It's difficult to put into words, >> That last time, but
last time they did that, no help was on the way. And President
Trump said, "Help is on the >> Slimy Slimy almost gets
there. No, it doesn't almost get there. Slimy doesn't get there.
It is evil. It is actually evil. Ben Shapiro is actually evil.
Like an evil human being.
And then President Trump acted. What happens next will be in
their hands. The drum beat of lies is absolutely incessant. Iran
is striking at surrounding countries. They're on the move. The
regime is more solid than ever. Iranians are rallying around
the flag. Now, if you watch X these days, that might be your
takeaway from the joint American Israeli action in Iran. UN
No, my my takeaway is
um elites in both countries, elites in Israel, elites in America
don't give a about spending American taxpayer dollars to get
something done. I get not even sure what their goals were to
begin with, but to do something that is going to leave all of
us poorer and in a worse position in life.
And you, Ben Shapiro, feel none of the effects of that. You feel
zero effect of that. You sit here advocating for all of these
things and you are not the person who pays the price. Honestly,
if Ben Shapiro was willing to popularize himself for his beliefs,
I would hate him 1% less. But he's not. He's he's being mean
he's being made rich by continuing to put forth this slob. It's
>> ending, whining, cataralling over a conflict less than
3 weeks old in which the United States has suffered by any military
historical standard the lowest casualties in the history of major
military conflict and has inflicted more damage by air than any
combined air operation in modern military history. Now, part
of the problem surely is actual false information. The New York
Times reported just a few days ago, quote, that they had identified
over 110 unique AI generated images and videos from the past
two weeks about the war in the Middle East. The fakes covered
every aspect of the fighting. They falsely depicted screaming
Israelis cowering as explosions ripped through Tel Aviv, Iranians
mourning their dead, American military vessels bombarded with
missiles and torpedoes. Collectively, they were seen millions
of times online through
some AI videos got made.
I look, dude, I imagine if instead of like criticizing what Ben
Shapiro is actually saying, I pulled up like the comments and
found the most insane conspiracy theorist Daily Wire viewers
and just went and fought with those people instead of actually
contending with any of the real arguments being made by real
people with any amount of reputation.
It would I couldn't get away with it. I couldn't get away with
it. And that's what he does. He just picks the worst people to
engage with because he knows he's wrong. networks like X, Tik
Tok, utter propaganda. >> The content has become a potentformational
weapon for Thran as it seeks to shake the public's tolerance
for war by depicting scenes of devastation and destruction across
the region. Now, of course, all of this does play on the inherent
weakness of the West, a West filled with moral imbeciles with
large platforms like say Lay McGawan, a person who I didn't know
except I guess she was on CNN and had somehow amassed 2 million
Instagram followers for brilliant commentary like
real life. We did not need to be in this war. We started the
war for no reason. Middle East
here. Iran started the war in 1979. We can't go back to 1979.
But we can take away
are exporting terror and death to all of their neighbors. They're
a menace to their neighbors. Every Middle Eastern country is
with us on this. >> Honestly, oh man. I I literally can't
I literally can't stream. I don't know what to do when somebody
says the year
Like I I just immediately want to say like put write that name
down. Okay, write that name down. We need that name for later.
Okay, people need that name for later. They say the year 1979.
You need that name, the person who said it for later. Okay, what?
What for? I don't know. I can't really say, but you need it for
later. It's going to be >> Everyone wants Iran taken out
of the
>> We are the bad guys here. Remember that was her line.
We are the bad guys here. How sick and perverse do you have to
be to look at Iran, a repressive tyranny that forces women into
particular forms of garb and hangs gay people and threatens all
of its neighbors and spreads terrorism all over the region and
tries to develop nuclear weapons so as to better spread terrorism
all over the region and say America is the bad guy. How perverse.
Or commentators like this over on MS. Now,
>> the other piece of this that I found really disturbing
in the messaging around the war recently, and Aman, I I really
want your thoughts on this in particular, is some of the language
and the description of their opponent, sort of the way they seem
to create this image of the Iranians and all of their sort of
proxies or or allies, uh, the sort of imagery that they conjure
up. And I think that it takes a certain amount of arrogance and
I'm also going to say it a bit of racism
to constantly talk about people like they are savages. That is
a word that we have heard Seth use. Uh talk about people as though
they are subhuman, too stupid to engage in a war with the United
States, incapable of possibly uh outmaneuvering us. Uh >> uh
this is kind of stupid. I literally don't care. I I don't care
if Pete Hit like makes the Iranian regime look stupid in military
operations. I literally I don't care. I don't care. I don't care.
>> And and
then find >> any chance we get a mention of the school
we bombed from Ben? No. Put >> ourselves in the exact position
in which it appears they are consistently outmaneuvering us.
>> You know what would be better than a mention of the
school that got bombed? Rhox, a mention of the fact that Pete
Hexith got rid of the the group that was tasked with preventing
civilian casualties. That would be even better. Okay,
they explicitly got rid of that. That seems pretty woke. Trying
not to kill kids. That sounds pretty woke, guys. Isn't that woke?
Huh? Bombing schools full of kids to own the libs. Let's [__]
go. >> Okay. First of all, they are not consistently outmaneuvering
us. We are kicking the living hell out of them. Second of all,
if you can't label the Iranian Revolutionary Guard Corps, which
shoots people in the streets by the tens of thousands or the
Mas orbah or Kamas or the Houthies
savages, I don't know when you would ever apply that term
the the perverse moral sickness of
>> you see if I'm trying to do I'm trying to think of how
you do the Finkelestein >> You see Ben
perhaps
those people are savages but
Israel is a thousand times worse. Okay, something like this.
Okay, I denounce these people but if you denounce these people
you must denounce Israel a 100 times. A thousand times >> of
these folks. Then of course there are people who are too dumb
even for MS now. So for example the extraordinarily dim-witted
Joy Reed who actually compares America to Iran and says that
basically America is like Iran. >> Our regime has secret
police. They have secret police. Our regime is oppressing women
taking away abortion rights. Taking away women's rights. >> Okay.
You can find a million to line up and it's not going to make
me unironically unironically this is what they're trying to do.
This has to be the limit. Okay. I've mentioned it. The Hassan
bad thing is like an extension of the conservative strategy.
When people do the Hassan bad thing, that is just an extension
of like the conservative strategy, which is like, oh, wokes are
bad. Wokes are woke people are bad. Democrats are bad. The left
is evil. They want to transfer kids. It's the same thing. It's
like, can I make this person so bad that you'll allow me to do
Guess what, Ben? I don't care how soy Joey Reed is. I don't care.
I don't give a about how soy Joy Reed is. I don't give a
It's not going to make this war palatable. It's not going to
make it okay. Okay? It doesn't matter how many woke you line
up who are going to say
it's not going to make this okay. It will never make it okay.
I don't care how dude you could put somebody way worse up here.
You could put Keflals up here. I wouldn't give a
All right. Keles could be up here talking about how badly some
little needs estrogen tomorrow. Purity blockers and estrogen.
And it still wouldn't make me go, "Oh, actually, yeah, dude.
Bomber on. Yeah, bombaran right now." No, no, no, no, no.
Sorry, Ruben. Ruben, I'll go back to your donation in like 26
uh 26 states. Some states where they're trying to have the death
penalty for having an abortion. They also oppress women. They're
they uh have the highest rate of women who are in STEM careers.
We're kicking women out of the military, out of university. >> Wow.
It's like Iran doesn't really repress women at all. So true,
Joy Reed.
This person's I don't give a [__] >> We're
saying that uh DEI means women can't be hired for high positions
in the sciences. We So we're we're marginally better and we're
doing it for Christianity. They're doing it for Islam. Right.
>> Well, we're doing it for Christianity. They're doing
it for Islam. For for Christianity, would that be allowing people
like Joy Reid to have a major platform and continue to be a prominent
person talking about how terrible America is in comparison with
Iran? And then of course there are dumb asses like Dave Smith,
a comedian whose only joke is apparently his understanding of
Muslim history. He put out a statement just a couple of days
ago. Quote, "Islam is such a violent religion. Every time we
murder a bunch of their children, they try to kill some of us."
Disgusting.
I mean, >> w Dave Smith, let's go. >> How does Dave
Smith think that Islam became a regional power? Literally, the
entire history of Islam is conquest and killing lots of people.
Like, that is a reality. Islam historically bad guys.
um actually you know
okay the Ottoman Empire reaches its end at the be earlier 1400
or something okay oh my god guys just go back like 600 years
and it was a really big problem. Then of course there is gym
teacher stinging laser theorizing genius Marjgerie Taylor Green
who I have to say the the trajectory of her strange new respect
is astonishing.
Everyone on the left recognized actually I think quite properly
that she is of double-digit IQ and a conspiratorial nut to boot.
And now because she doesn't like President Trump, she's given
a slot basically every night on CNN or MS Now to rip into the
president strange new respect. And here is Marjorie Taylor Green.
Why would an American president lead his political party into
the midterms waging a full-scale major war completely unprovoked
on on Iran um on behalf >> Yeah, dude. You're not going
to line up. It doesn't matter how many you line up to give bad
opinions. Engage with the actual good critiques, Ben. Engage
with the good critiques. Engage with the actual critiques.
Where is the interest for Americans in preventing Iran from getting
a nuclear weapon? I thought that's what Midnight Hammer was for.
So admit that Midnight Hammer was a total failure or explain
to me why they're going to have a weapon in two weeks. >> Half
of Israel and that's the way most Americans see it. They see
this is for Israel, not for America. Why would an American president
do that which is forcing gas prices to hike right here going
into spring break where families are going to be driving out
of town going into summer um declaring and and waging a major
full-scale war that that seems to have no end in sight that is
not deescalating it's escalating every >> I will say you
can tell how weak the arguments are on the pro- Iran war side
that Ben has to engage with the height of he has to engage with
the most opinions he can find to have any chance of looking intelligent.
He cannot engage with anybody who's serious. He can only engage
with Marjgery Taylor Green and Joy Reed. These are his intellectual
contemporaries. Okay. >> A single day. And um it just doesn't
make sense. And the uh the American people did not vote for this.
This is not what we campaign for. Pamela,
>> uh no, I don't believe I don't believe MTG is the She's
not a Christian Zionist. She's not. Christian Zionist would never
hypothesize face lasers in the first place.
>> Okay. Um Marjgerie Taylor Green was basically thrown
out of Congress by President Trump. Now listen, there are a lot
of people, as it turns out, who are >> pretty sure Trump
was like kind of annoyed that she left, right? Wouldn't that
further like depress their >> This moment as a moment to
take their shot at President Trump. Now, most of them won't actually
cite Trump by name because they're still afraid of him, but they're
doing it anyway. One of those people is Joe Kent. He's a failed
congressional candidate who was repeatedly backed by President
Trump in Washington state. And then he was >> here's the
Joe here's the Joe Kent >> Appointed by President Trump
to head the National Counterterrorism Center as a deputy of director
of national intelligence Tulsi Gabbard. Well, this morning, Joe
Kent quit his job at the National Counterterrorism Center and
issued a scathing letter designed to undermine President >> What
is What is Ben Shapiro going to say about Joe Kent, American
war hero and gold star like widowerower?
Widow widow. Yeah, widowerower like gold star widowerower. Guy
who gave everything for America. Guy gave his everything in his
life for America. What is Ben Shapiro going to say about that
guy? >> President Trump. The letter is deeply deeply conspiratorial.
It states openly that quote Iran posed no imminent threat to
our nation and it is clear that we started this war due to pressure
from Israel and its powerful American lobby.
Now that is conspiracy trash. It's >> No, it's not. And
everybody who tries to paint this as talking points or something
is a complete
maybe maybe you could say when he gets to the Iraq war part that
you feel that that's like anti-Semitic conspiracy. I would not
say that Israel caused the Iraq war to happen. I would say there
were factions in the Israeli I guess coalition, the Israeli government
or Israeli leadership who wanted Iraq and Saddam to be taken
down and they had sway over American leadership but it wasn't
like direct control. It wasn't blackmail. It was arguing his
arguing their points, arguing why it would happen, right? Iraq
was for oil, not 100% for Israel. No, it it yes, Israel was like
one of the exacerbating factors. It was not like the whole thing
at all. Okay. >> It's also kind of strange since President
Trump has said that it's conspiracy trash. So apparently Trump
is so deeply deeply enthralled to those strange powerful American
lobbies. We're not going to say it. We're not going to say it.
We're not going to say that he he apparently has been so bamboozled
by He literally said the Israel lobby. He literally said Apac.
He literally said the Israel lobby. Bro, what do you mean? Oh,
we're not going to say it. But he literally was like, "Hey,
Apac
forced us into this war. Israel's overwhelming influence forced
us into this war." Okay. And then Ben sits here. Oo, don't say
it. No, we're Everybody's saying it now. Congratulations, Ben.
You've put half of the planet against Israel now. More than half
the planet, probably. Congratulations. I hope this is what you
guys wanted.
>> Can lobbies. We're not going to say We're not deeply
enthralled to those strange powerful American lobbies. We're
not going to say it. We're not going to say it. We're not going
to say that he he apparently has been so bamboozled by >> Yeah,
I there's no problem with saying it now. Congrats, Ben. There
is zero issue with saying it now. We can just say Apac. We can
just say uh Israel is way too much influence over the American
government, over American Congress people. Israel has too much
influence. It's a it's a it's a Zionist occup No, it's not. But
you know it's a it's a certainly a Zionist suede government.
K
rhinox keeps linking this guy >> that Saddam is seeking
>> there is no question whatsoever that Saddam is seeking
and is working and is advancing towards the development of nuclear
weapons. No question whatsoever. There is no
Who's I don't recognize this guy. This guy doesn't have anything
to do with Israel. Right. This guy's like an American politician.
This guy doesn't have anything to do with Israel at all. Right.
Right. By them that he's still under the impression that he's
his own man. But here's the thing. President Trump is his own
man. He makes his own decisions. And as per our usual arrangement,
Trump's critics are cowards who are simply unwilling to acknowledge
>> he wasn't prime minister. He was just the equivalent
of a senator.
Wait, he was also I believe at that point, wouldn't he have been
like four years removed from being prime minister, six years
removed from being prime minister?
He literally was just prime minister like right before that.
Like it's not like he wasn't it's not like people didn't know
who he was that Trump is the one making the call. But Joe Kent
continued, quote, "Early in this administration, high-ranking
Israeli officials and influential members of the American media
deployed a misinformation campaign that wholly undermined your
America first platform and swed pre-war sentiments to encourage
a war with Iran. This echo chamber was used." >> Yeah,
you're 100% raw. Wrong. Bad AB. He first became per prime minister
of Israel in 1996.
Totally wrong. Then he had then his party lost. And then Ariel
Chiron took over as the leader of Lood, but he was still a part
of Lakood. He was still winning his seat. And then after Ariel
Chiron died, he took back over as prime minister uh via the Lakood
coalition. Used to deceive you into believing that Iran posed
imminent threats to the United States and that should you strike
now, there was a clear path to a swift victory. This was a lie
and is the same tactic the Israelis used to draw us into the
disastrous Iraq war that cost our nation the lives of thousands
of our best men and women. Again, the idea here seems to be that
President Trump is a [__] misled into war by nefarious
Israelis and unnamed influential. Yes, he actually got it right.
Yes. Yes, Ben.
People are like, "Oh, you shouldn't blame Israel because it gets
it gives Trump an out." No, Trump is the who's listening to these
people. Yes, Trump is a total
Biden with his brain melting out of his ears knew not to go to
war with Iran.
Okay. Yes, Donald Trump is a yesial members of the American media.
Don't say it. Don't say it. Again, apparently, President Trump
has no agency and no thoughts. Kent's letter is replete with
this conspiratorial idiocy.
>> Don't say it. Don't say it. Don't say it. Uh total Zionist
shills like you, Ben. like Lindsey Graham. Not all of them are
okay. Total Zionist shills like you, Ben. Like you. Nobody's
afraid to say it's you. You're the problem.
Okay. It's you. Including, as we just saw, the idea that it was
Israel that
>> I wonder how the libs I wonder how the libs that are
making this I don't know what you're saying. I wonder how the
libs who are making this argument sleep with like sleep at night
or live with themselves. I don't know.
They seem to have and not they're basically falling victim to
the exact same propaganda that Ben's putting out here just from
a different lens, right? They're like, "Oh, anti-semites are
so bad that whatever they say, I'm going to run from that." Like,
if you show them a picture of Nick Fuentes, they will [__]
their pants and go, "Yeah, blow up Iran. Nuke on right now. OH
MY GOD, NICK FUENTES. THAT GUY'S REALLY BAD. NUKEON NOW. NUKEON
NOW." It's like, okay, no, you maybe just think for a second.
Maybe just use your brain for two seconds. How about that? How
about that? >> Forced the original Iraq war. An idea totally
and utterly unsupportable by any evidence given the fact that
the actual prime minister of Israel at the time, Ariel Chiron,
opposed the Iraq war. This stuff is brain rot. Now listen, we
should all be thankful for Joe Kent's long and honorable military
service. We can also be glad that he's leaving since his ideology
is the same as that of Tucker Carlson, the guy who says that
the war is disgusting and evil and who has been busy with the
Mullas. Tucker Carlson calls Kent a personal friend and quote
the bravest man I know. Frankly, I think that it is a good thing
that Kent is not in this position. We cannot have a director
of counterterrorism who is somehow advocating preemptive surrender
to the world's leading state sponsor of terrorism in the middle
of a war. Now, the question here is not why Joe Kent would do
this. He's been a longtime devote of a foreign policy utterly
at odds with the peace through strength foreign policy of President
Trump. President Trump, we played clips on the show, has been
advocating for ending the Iranian threat by military force for,
I don't know, 47 years. Jok,
hey, there's another name, guys. Look, there's another name.
You say 47 years, I know that you're somebody you trust me.
47 years, 1979.
Name goes on a board. Name goes on a board. Name goes on a board.
Okay. Every single time. You're If you're going to try to defend
this war and you say 1979 or 47 years,
they've been they've been attacking us for 47 years. Yeah. Name
goes on a board. Okent by contrast is a devote of Ron Paul. He's
also the same guy who suggested that the West was trying to manufacture
a war with Russia and backed Vladimir Putin's aggressive play
for Ukrainian territory as quote very reasonable. The real question
is why Joe Kent was appointed in the first place and also which
other members of the administration are trying to undermine the
president from within. It's not all that hard to tell to be honest
with you. If you see a proisolationist story printed at Politico
or Axios or a story from the administration doubts inside the
administration about the president's war arguments behind closed
doors the president was misinformed. You can bet money where
it comes from. Spoiler alert, it likely rhymes with Tulsi Gabbard's
office. I would assume that is why Dave Smith is now calling
on Tulsi to quit too and throw her own punches at the president
in the process. It is also presumably why Candace Owen
pro isolationist. Am I high? Didn't Trump literally run on this?
Yes. Yes. Uh guys, you can bet if somebody's complaining about
Donald Trump lying to the voters that totally going back on every
promise he made to his voters, somebody's complaining about that,
you can blame it on I it doesn't even matter what name you say.
He says Tulsi Gabbard, which actually pisses me off because I
assume whatever name follows is going to be a literal patriot.
Somebody who's calling out liars in their own party who are working
against the will of the people.
Unfortunately, in this case, that may be Tulsi Gabbard's office.
I don't believe that. I believe Tulsi Gabbard is a totally soulless
shill. Okay. I don't believe she's actually working against the
president. I do believe some people around her who believed her
and took her seriously might think that
>> has been out there tweeting in support of Joe Kent and
suggesting that the president of the United States is as always
the real problem. It's not just the grievance right of course
some of these folks like Pete Buddhajed Choo Choo Train lover
former failed mayor of Southbend Indiana but at least he's gay
simply spewing silly lines about how diplomacy with Iran was
totally totally totally working. I mean it wasn't working but
it was totally working you see. So the Trump administration argues
that they needed to take action to take out Iran's nuclear weapons
program and Iran's ballistic missile program. Um because when
they came into office, the Biden administ >> like unfortunately
I don't trust any actor in this equation.
But just like ba I believe basically working your way through
this logically. You can tell what's happening, right? You can
tell what's going on. You just have to think about it a little
bit. Iran doesn't want war with the US. Iran is not okay going
like fail to to respond to any attempts at diplomacy because
that them over, right? They're going to try.
Absolutely they're going to try.
I just
the idea that no attempt at diplomacy would work. Of course,
they're going to try to avoid war with the United States. They
don't want to have all their get blown up. They don't want any
they don't want anything like this. Nobody wanted this except
for
except for
ex wait who who no I'm not going to do >> your administration
had done >> I'll leave it an open-ended question >> nothing
in four years to stop Iran from building a nuclear weapon developing
>> they literally all scream bad AB you're you're just
that's fine somebody can hate you and have no capacity to deal
you real harm and know that you have all the capacity in the
world to deal them real harm and they will shut shut the [__]
up. Right? They won't they won't do things to get killed. Right?
That's the whole thing with Iran is Iran would act within what
was possible, what was like rational. They're rational actors.
Painting them as totally irrational actors. Actually, totally.
It totally does a disservice to how dangerous that regime is.
They're they're totally rational actors. They're never going
to try to put the US enough. That's why they could have shut
down the straight of Hormuz at any point. Why would they do that?
To let Hold on. But they're not strong enough to harm. Midnight
Hammer just took out a bunch of They have no air defense.
How in the world are they going to build up a capacity to hurt
anybody? Oh, you're you're a totally mindless zbot. Okay, so
M midnight hammer totally failed then, I guess. Okay, Midnight
Hammer totally failed. And not only that, they apparently discovered
a way they discovered the technology to make a bomb and they
discovered ballistic missiles to put that bomb on. Yeah.
Even though there's no intelligence, not even reports from the
US themselves that this is the case and multiple members of Congress
have come out and said that they had no capacity to strike the
United States in any way. Why why did this have to happen now
when the global economy is like buckling at the seams? Why couldn't
this have waited? Why couldn't they have collected more intelligence
and just chilled bad AB? They have there is no indication. There
is zero intelligence reports. There is zero information in the
public that suggests they have the technology to build a nuclear
weapon. Do you understand? To weaponize like uranium,
you need a core and you need a trigger. They have neither. They've
not figured that out. They don't have the technology from anybody
else as far as anybody knows. Israel has essentially like full
transparency into that government. The US has nearly full transparently
into that government.
Why did the IEA
say there was no evidence of weaponization program? Yeah, exactly.
They had enriched uranium, but bad AB, you are one of the worthless
cattle who hears that they have enriched uranium and you think
that's the same as a weapon. You understand that's not the same
as a weapon, right? Answer my question. You understand that's
not the same as a weapon, right? Why else would they expl Why
else would they enrich? Because they're trying to because they
basically didn't get their uh what do you call it? The um JCPOA.
They're trying to present the idea that they could go and do
this without actually pursuing the technology. And by the way,
if they have a multi-year timing, if they have a multi-year window
before they're actually going to be nuclear capable to to carry
out any significant nuclear strike, why would you hit them now?
Because they're trying to. And hold on. Do you think you just
won? Because they're trying to.
Because they're trying to.
Oh, because they're weak. Okay. Well, guess what? Now you get
to decide. bad AB
when when some single mother can't give gifts to her kids this
Christmas and she tells her kids, "Listen, listen, listen, sweetheart,
I know it's tough without gifts, but you have to understand,
we reduced Iran's capacity
to build nuclear or sorry, build ballistic missiles by 90%."
And that's important. That's more important than
How do you think the American people are going to take that having
to give explanations like that? Austerity for you. Security for
Israel. Let's go. Let's go.
You've been crying for Ukraine. Yes. Why would you think I don't
support Ukraine wholeheartedly? I absolutely support Ukraine
wholeheartedly. What the
nuke Moscow tomorrow?
That's crazy. >> Ballistic missiles funding terrorism around
the world. >> Are they wrong? >> Find me a single
Hold on. Find me a single point I've ever said something nice
about Putin. >> What? This is totally re You're making
things up. The are you talking about? Why do I have the Ukraine
thing as a kickote? A paid kickote.
Show me the Russian flag I have. It's literally talking about
the major geopolitical conflicts of the the sides I support.
Taiwan, Ukraine, Palestine. What the This guy just comes in here,
makes some >> Yes, of course they're wrong. I mean, for
one thing, the president assured us that the nuclear program,
President Trump assured us that the nuclear program was, in his
words, obliterated just a few months ago. And let's also remember
that in the past, Iran's nuclear program was contained without
a shot being fired. And President >> Wait, do I not have
a Palestinian flag? Are we still on the Israel flag? Oops. My
bad. We're still on the Israel flag. That's my bad.
Although, yeah, actually, we could just call it the Palestinian
flag and then we seem way more extreme. No, that's the Palestinian
flag now. That's the That is the land that will become Palestine.
>> Trump thought he could get a better deal than the Obama
administration did. He failed to get that better deal and he
went off and launched a war without >> I mean, I think
that we should probably listen to Pete Buddhajred.
>> Although to be fair, that is JTO. Is that flag? So,
pretty awesome. >> Whose latest tac is hanging out at diners
and trying to look more tough and rough so he can run for president.
I mean, he does have >> bad abb. You are just total cattle.
You You just made some [__] up. You got mad. You
made some [__] up. Okay,
you're just cattle. You're cattle posting in my chat right now.
Keep the cattle posting to a minimum. Okay.
Very embarrassing. >> Longer facial hair than he used to.
Some are like Howdy Duty looking creepy youth pastor James Terico
promoting Rubebait about how we're spending too much money in
this war. You see, it's a misdirection of resources. Listening
to Democrats whine about how much money we spend is um a brain
rot of its own. By the way, for the record, we are spending about
a billion dollars a day on this war. We spend in America every
single day for the rest of time at least$20
billion dollar every day forever at the federal level. Here is
except you're the [__] Oh, this guy wants to be This
guy really wants to bait slurs out of me. Except every time somebody
wants to take money aside and put it towards something like healthcare,
Ben, you do a whole piece about how those people are communists.
So you could say, "Oh, well, we spend a lot of money anyway.
Why is it communism for Israel? We have to take care of Israel
but not anything. No social programs for Americans. Why is it
that way, Ben?
Why do you support communism for Israel and not for anyone else?
>> James Telerico saying the war is just too costly. Oh,
yeah. By the way, we should have universal childare or >> I
was in Sand Branch, Texas a few week. >> Yeah, Ben Ben
is literally offended at the anti-Semitic thought that you should
have universal child care instead of a war in Iran. That's actually
deeply offensive to Ben.
The idea that you would want universal childare instead of a
war with Iran. Wow. >> Weeks ago, it's a community south
of Dallas that doesn't have any running water. It doesn't have
basic sewer
So, every dollar that we are spending bombing people in the Middle
East is a dollar that we are not spending in our communities
back home. This sort of rhetoric is always unbelievably stupid
because it turns out the American government spends, you know,
like $7 trillion a year. But maybe you find these arguments convincing.
If so, that's your prerogative. It's a free country. But just
understand, you are not hearing an accurate depiction of the
thing that's actually going on. You are very often hearing either
politically motivated nonsense or actual agit prop designed to
undermine America's incipient victory in Iran. Now again this
does not mean that we don't have some outstanding problems in
the action in Iran. The large of these remains the straight of
Hormuz. All righty. Traffic in the straight of Hormuz as we have
been discussing has been dropping precipitously since the beginning
of the Iran action. Western flags or link tankers have stopped
transiting the waterway at least until the action is over or
until they receive an American escort. Mayor, MSSE, Hape Lloyd,
they've all suspended transits. Despite America's vow to ensure
shipping, most companies aren't actually taking America up on
it. Meanwhile, Iran, >> I think all you should say is um
if Israel is willing to take out debt for all American munitions
used, if they were willing to pay the debt of any American action
taken, right? We just add that to just add that to Israel's debt
instead of America's. Then are we all good? Why didn't anybody
come up with this? Isn't this the art of the deal, baby? Let's
go put that debt on Israel or it's in our self-interest as well.
It's not. You're [__] again. You are just sitting
here trying to cattle post and irritate me. Stop being cattle.
Okay. No imminent threat. Not required right now. Could have
been done in a way better way. Okay. Clearly, they had no idea
what they're doing. They said, "Oh, we're going to make the regime
fall." They had no idea what the situation was.
Embarrassing. Has been launching drones at ports in the area.
They're attempting to ramp up pressure on America to end the
conflict. Now again, if America were to just do that, that would
really be dumb because then Iran would be in basic permanent
control of this vital choke point in global trade. So what's
the thing that comes next? The Wall Street Journal laid out a
few options this morning. They wrote, quote, retired Rear Admiral
Mark Montgomery, who has commanded a carrier strike group, recently
laid out what a Hormuz operation might look like. First, continue
to degrade to a militarily manageable risk the missiles, mines,
drones, unmanned surface combatants that could threaten US forces
and tankers. Second, maintain an unblinking eye that looks 50
miles on either side of the straight and 100 miles back. Third,
keep four or eight aircraft persistently overhead during convoy
operations equipped with advanced precision kill weapon systems,
a cheap rocket, 25,000 bucks that is extremely effective against
shahad drones. Fourth, have to arm hilos ready to attack small
boats that emerge. Fifth, deploy 10 to 14 Aegis destroyers whose
air defenses make them the perfect escort ship. These surface
combatants first need to be brought into place. Allies could
join later. So, that is one possibility. It's timeconuming. It's
expensive obviously. Or alternatively, President Trump could
seize Kar Island as we have been talking about. Car Island is
at Coral Island located. Is he going to suggest that seizing
Car Island opens the straight?
How does seizing Car Island open the straight? I have I can't
wait to hear whatever thing Ben's about to say. Holy.
I didn't think it get any worse, guys. Or instead of trying to
escort ships to the We could seize Car Island.
Okay. Is Car Island immune from the problem? So the problem right
now is everybody has had to shut down oil production because
they can't hold their oil reserves past a certain point. The
person the the country that had the most capacity to store the
reserves, right, to pull oil out of the ground and store it was
Saudi Arabia at about 5 weeks maximum. All right. Every country
is slowly having to shut all their operations down because these
are pipeline operations. It takes weeks and months to spin them
back up, right?
Seizing Car Island does not solve this problem that you can't
transit the Straight of Hormuz.
You could say it's leverage. It's It's not good leverage. What
can Iran do with the money it makes right now to keep the straight
of Hormuz closed? Like, what is Iran doing?
What What are they getting out of sending their oil out that
is actually making it so they could continue to shut down the
straight of Hormuz? Answer, nothing. answer. All of the infrastructure,
all the the drones, the the boats, everything they have, all
of that, right, is already there. If you destroy Car Island,
that at best just hurts Iran long term. It doesn't do anything.
You seize Car Island, I mean, at best you stop them from earning
money, possibly. Okay. >> About 15 miles off the coast
of Iran and literally 90% of all Iranian oil capacity moves through
Khar Island. If we were to seize it, it would cut off Iran's
export entire capacity entirely and that would likely either
force the regime to negotiate an end to the war or it would lead
to sort of a final Iranian conflration that might end in the
fall of the regime because when you don't got no money and when
you don't got no oil going out and when the United States is
sitting on your entire oil supply things start to get pretty
rough. What is President Trump actually going to do? >> So
your solution, Ben, the thing that apparently is going to break
everybody
is the exact thing that Iran's already done to every Gulf country.
You're basically going to be able to
go back to Oh, also,
if they seize Car Island, they will just have uh they will just
mine the straight because they have no need to keep it navigable
anymore.
Oh, I
I mean, it might be hard for them to mine the island to be honest
with you. I don't know how they'll do that with like fishing
boats or something. They're going to go in the middle of the
night with fishing boats. I don't even know what they're going
to do if they want to try to mine the straight. But yeah, if
if Car Island is destroyed or seized, they could just start being
even more aggressive about what they're doing with the straight
itself.
>> Is interesting. Very interesting. >> He's certainly
not going to tell the members of the press. One of my favorite
games that President Trump plays is somebody asks him a specific
question on what he's about to do and then he just rips on them.
It's kind of funny. Will it be necessary to use even a limited
ground force to secure whatever nuclear material remains in Iran
is part of that threat? And secondly, have you made a >> You
mean to go in and get it? >> Yes sir. >> Uh why would
I tell you that? >> Sorry. The answer is yes. You would
need So that is one of the major concerns is as this regime if
they do get the regime to fracture actually all the nuclear material
they've gathered
could easily just make its way out of the country.
You could easily lose track of it. And then you've got theocratic
like lunatics with a whole bunch of enriched nuclear material
god knows where. Cool. That's very cool. That's going to be awesome.
>> You know, I I can't stand, sir, will you attack Car
Island?
Will you occupy car? They ask me these questions
and I don't want to be mean, but they're stupid questions. If
if any if any
>> unfortunately they don't the funny thing he's about
to say if any other president got these questions. No other president
gets these questions because no other president is enough to
answer these questions on a regular basis. You are the
think you are. That's why they ask you questions that only a
real would answer because 50% of the time you answer the question.
This is so insulting. I can't believe you asked me this question.
No, you're the who answers these questions all the time. president
answered those questions. They shouldn't be president.
>> I mean, he's right about that. But back to opening the
straight for just a moment. President Trump has been calling
on our allies from Europe to Asia. >> Uh they already have
these already. Sorry, they already have these tenstone.
These things are already there
>> to help open up the straight. These allies freely acknowledge
that. >> Hypothetically, if they killed a 100 American
citizens and we evaded that didn't happen. Hypothetically, if
they did some terrorist attack to murder a bunch of American
civilians, hypothetically, then maybe you could get like right
now they planned that and they executed it, then maybe you could
get some idea of war. But even then, invading Iran is stupid
and you would need way more hardware there to keep the straight
open, which they didn't do.
But realistically, I would say anybody serving on bases in the
in the Middle East, I'm not considering civilians in the same
way. You're basically saying, "Well, they plan to kill civilians
in the Middle East who were at bases." No. No. That was only
going to happen if Israel hit them. That was it. That was a situation
Israel was forcing. So again,
it's they didn't have this ability to present this threat to
America in the same way. And
right now, America is basically in a recession. Outside of AI
spending, America's in a recession. And they've decided while
in a recession, they're going to go to war. an extremely costly
war that is basically going to increase the go it's going to
exacerbate any possible inflation, right? Like we're going to
all see inflation and not like inflation as in monetary policy
inflation. We're going to see actual increased cost of goods,
right? Like all of our cost our cost of goods are going to go
up so much, right? Wait, I literally answered the question. I
said, "Oh, well, maybe you could make that argument if they had
killed a hundred Americans." Like if they did a
killed 100 Americans, maybe even then I think you do limited
strikes that just destroy their capacity. But I think I think
you hit them back in a way that actually with them like here's
the thing. You're giving me a hypothetical where the response
from America there could just be to blow Car Island up to just
put that into the Gulf, right? And then that country is economically
devastated. Iran doesn't do that, right? Even when Iran does
go to strike Americans, they go they dial the president. They
go, "Excuse me, Mr. President. I think we're going to have to
Could you just let us hit this base, please? Please could you
just let us hit this base cuz like we don't want to look
Thanks. Thanks. That's the relationship America and Iran had.
>> That freedom of transit through the straight is in fact
a key strategic interest for not only the United States but for
everybody. It's just that they are too cowardly to do anything
about it. You know, as usual, as per our usual arrangement, they
bring the empty talk, we bring the hardware. As of now, Japan
has announced they're not going to send ships to help us, even
though 93%
of all of their oil transits the straight of Hormuz. South Korea,
same story. Even though 70 to 75% of their oil comes through
that waterway, Britain has been offering us a few mind sweeper
drones. France wants stability first, which is to say they want
a partial surrender to the Iranians. Australia, they're doing
nothing.
China, of course, is on the other side. They're aligned with
Iran. They're calling for an end to the war. All this despite
the fact that an oil shock harms all of those countries significantly
more than it harms the United States. As the Wall Street Journal
reports today, >> unfortunately, Ben is leaving out the
part where downstream
that's where we get all of our manufactured goods from is like
like basically the Indopacific.
So, while the oil shock [__] them, it also using
costs are surging across the continent. Government debt in the
UK and France is at or near the highest share of GDP in at least
six decades. So what are the Europeans actually going to do?
What what are they fighting hard for? They're fighting for green
energy. I know, I know. Oh, the Europeans. They're clinging to
their fatuous emissions trading systems. Those are regulations
on carbon emissions as their prices continue to climb through
the ceiling. Here's Ursula Vanderlane, who's the head of the
European Commission. Without ETS,
we would now consume 100 billion cubic meter more gas. Again,
making us more vulnerable, more dependent, and weaker.
So, we need ETSs, but we need to modernize it. >> Oh, great.
I mean, they're focused on the right things. So, that would be
a yes on the solar panels, and that would be a no on joining
America to end the terrorist regime in Iran. So, let's talk a
little bit about our vaunted allies. We've heard over and over
and over again that our allies are deeply important, that we
shouldn't abandon our allies, that our allies deserve our support.
I've advocated for this. I've been a huge advocate for that idea.
Not because I deeply love the French or the Germans or the Brits,
but because the world is a chaotic place and we would
>> Dude, I like at what point do you start leaning back
into if you want to be conspiratorial, at what point do you just
start leaning back into the conspiracy that Trump is like blackmailed
by Putin and he his goal as the president this time around is
basically to ensure the destruction of
Like at what point is that
a more likely scenario than like him being super compromised
by Israel or something else? cuz he just keeps making decisions
that are seem foundationally intended to destroy your country.
I honestly don't know
I don't know what you do to stop it. I I actually don't know
what you do to stop >> rather have countries on our side
than aligning with our enemies. But the time has come to discuss
what makes a good ally. A good ally in foreign policy isn't just
a country we pay to stay out of the sway of the enemy. A good
ally should do four things. First, our best allies should align
with us morally. They should share our general values and orientation
toward the world. We have strategic partners, and these strategic
partners may change over time and not share our values very much,
but our best allies ought to stand shoulderto-shoulder with us
in our civilizational outlook. Second, our allies should minimize
>> I can't believe he wasn't about to shill. I thought
for sure he was about to shill here.
>> Okay, whatever. He's going back to Europe. I think we're
probably done with